why launch it today
why release it today
do it today because everybody's going to
be talking about Trump and nobody's
going to be talking about this is their
real fear knowing because when you look
at the data the data shows that DeSantis
beats Biden head-on but Trump loses to
Biden by two points but Trump beats
DeSantis in the primary so they want to
make sure that Trump beats so so then
the argument becomes both ways because
some people could say Well they're
really trying to you know make sure
Trump wins this whole thing by going
after him like this this is helping it
is the you're thinking they're that
Machiavellian where they're gonna be
able to do to give these eyeballs to
Trump for him to beat the scientists do
they really think Trump needs this to
beat the centers so with or without this
do you think Trump's going to beat the
scientists with or without this does
Trump beat the santis